es hat nicht so einfach mal kann es ein
bisschen geld mitverdienen ja so aber
jetzt denke ich nur dass ich würde das
jetzt nicht wieder machen leute heute
ist ein tag auf den ich sehr lange
gewartet haben wir wissen wir schon eine
weile her actions und es gibt halt euch
gefällt mir gut ist es mega witzig sich
darüber lustig zu machen aber man kratzt
dann doch immer nur an der oberfläche
also man sieht nur das endprodukt die
hilfe erfolge und sieht nicht wie es
dazu kommt und welche leute das sind die
da zum beispiel mitspielen aber genau
das werden wir heute ändern denn ich bin
jetzt werden auch in köln aber mache
mich jetzt auf dem weg vereine schon
damit im auto um eine hilf mir
darstellerinnen zu interviewen
[Musik]
und jetzt könnte man es hässlich von
deshalb dass wir geben uns ganz völlig
hat man isst du warst beihilfen und du
warst andere jessie j hat eben schon
eine sache gesagt kann man ja immer
vorneweg raus haben die folge der duh
aufgetaucht ist die kampf vor einem
monat oder so aber waren auch die liebe
dreht wird glauben wird es haben reisen
15 15 starb im märz 2015 also die
webseiten quasi uralte fernsehfolgen die
sie vor jahren beigetreten auf der
festplatte draufmachen auf youtube das
gerade quasi und dann übrigens als
flüssige selbst gesehen hast du selbst
die einmal im fernsehen gesehen aber
auch nur den anfang weil das ende das
muss ich mir da nicht angucken weil dass
es selbst für mich entscheiden also war
das ende das vielleicht auch nicht auf
youtube glaube ich nicht dass es da
eigentlich ich glaube aber dass es halt
auf der originalseite kannst du kurz
sagen was da passiert weil ich weiß es
auch nicht also ich hatte des meisters
ja gesehen hat mit dieser mutter
dein lieblingsessen wenn wir uns kauft
was hältst du davon du hast halte stress
ja das wusste ich wirklich essen geben
dass du musst das marina mit kakao
ersten also sie haben eigentlich gesagt
dass ich noch mehr davon essen soll aber
ich hab das jetzt nicht mehr weil das
halt einfach ekelhaft ist und da haben
sie sich schon immer darauf eingelassen
da kann es am ende darauf wurde dann nur
noch volle kasse wurde dann nur noch
gesagt das halt alles wieder gut würde
und ja keine ahnung hatte das ich lag
irgendwie noch zusammengebrochen auf der
straße natürlich ja
das ist interessant was du sagst du
musst das quasi marin cacau erst mal
drauf ich auch so ein bisschen den
auswechseln müssen darüber reden wider
so die mit den darstellungen gegangen
wird man eigentlich gut also ich wurde
angerufen und gefragt auch wichtige
rolle halt machen ich glaube ich war
schon froh wie fing es an überhaupt ja
so man wird angerufen als ich das erste
mal ab 2013 oder so da war ich das erste
mal meinen verdachtsfälle und so lassen
irgendwann wurde ich dann halt dafür
dann
und auch fragen halt immer ob ich lust
habe ich zeit hatte für die rolle und
einer kleinen die einheit die rolle so
geschnitten weil man dann halt ja sagt
dann bekommt man halt das drehbuch
zugeschickt und da hat alles mögliche
durch und damit war ich ja eigentlich
zufrieden weil halt in dem drehbuch
nicht geschluckt und stammen oder so
ja und als ich dann da wurden dann halt
alles so sagt ein bisschen so verdreht
so ja das war so geplant
obwohl ich davon nichts wusste weil da
war halt ja auch die szene wo ich ein
bild von mir im internet waren
hallo und eigentlich war geplant dass
die szene sein sollte wo ich komplett
nur in unterwäsche und da habe ich
gesagt das mache ich nicht weil ich ja
da auch schon youtube gemacht habe und
mir dann darf schon klar so nie wir
gucken ja auch jüngere leute zu und
sowas will ich vor allem auch von mir
selber gar nicht im fernsehen und da
habe ich dann halt versucht irgendwie
ganz einfach umzudrehen aber da muss ich
schon sagen bei der folge habe ich mich
von allem wo ich bisher zwar unruhig ok
also übrigens man deshalb auch katzen
dass ich mal was da läuft was man so
dinge von denen nicht erwartet hat dass
du sie machen solltest aber die
situation verlangt haben war ja dass ich
mich da halt ausziehen
dass ich halt diese brutaler essen soll
also das war endlich darf ich auf das
ekelhaft schon hardcore eigentlich wird
und der hand
am ende taucht eingelassen aber sonst
aber es ist tatsächlich so dass habe ich
nämlich auch schon mal gehört wo das bei
solchen drews die die leute vor
irgendwas erzählen dann kommst du denn
da hin und dann sagen sie ja wir uns
sehr so gemeint und über den druck auf
dich aus dass es meistens so am anfang
wie gesagt am telefon haben wir komplett
anders gesagt und dann war ich halt da
und da haben wir ein komplett anderes
erzählt und habe aber halt auch darauf
bestanden dass ich das machen weil so
steht's im drehbuch
so muss das gemacht habe ich gesagt ist
es mir egal sind es so gemacht wird dann
mache ich nicht mehr mit damit hat euch
ein neues personal das mit an egal
und da war halt auch schon die hälfte
davon abgedreht und dann haben sie
gesagt ja okay was anderes als so zu
machen wie sich das möchte bleibt uns
nicht weil sonst ein sind liga zufolge
noch mal neu drehen müssen wie waren so
die leute da also müssen sie mit ihr
umgegangen also das team an sicher
halten megawatt aber halt diese von didi
sagt kloos und die produktion die
wahrheit so ein bisschen so eine sache
die mich interessiert haben auch viele
zuschauer gefragt weiß nicht nur darüber
reden willst darfst wird man da
angemessen entschädigt dafür sondern der
konsument spielt also zum damaligen
zeitpunkt würde ich sagen ja
und weil da hatte ich weit war ich so
viel mit geld und so zu tun da war es
zeit für mich schon viel geld wenn man
es jetzt aber ich glaube wenn ich es
jetzt noch mal würde ich es nicht aber
ich finde jetzt rückblickend finde ich
es auf jeden fall zu wenig was man dafür
bekommt also es ist jetzt nicht so dass
man da so einen euro die stunde bekommt
das jetzt nicht aber ich würde es nicht
mehr machen was ich will den gesamten
einfach gar nicht mehr machen darfst du
darüber reden noch konkrete zahlen oder
willst du darfst du nicht okay also ich
sag mal so ich habe irgendwann gehört so
um die ich weiß nicht 100 bis 500 euro
pro drehtag den dreh kann das vielleicht
sei da muss nichts dazu sagen aber ich
glaube also grob diese größenordnung ist
viel kleiner tanja com na okay alles
klappt was würdest du sagen willst denn
dein leben verändert seitdem da
dabei war es nicht nur nicht es kann
schon vorher manchmal kurz geredet haben
das kam erst im fernsehen dann auf
youtube und als es im fernsehen war da
noch nicht so oft angesprochen mal und
da man könne aber seitdem ist auf
youtube ist da geht es mehr und beide
wie wie sind die reaktionen sind wir
dann verstehen die das das geschaut wird
ist oder so ernst warum willst du marine
was ist mit dir sagen 70 bis 80 prozent
die bisschen halt dass das zuspiel
das steht ja auch gemacht haben anfangs
aber dann gibt's halt wieder diese leute
die denken dass er echt und dann
schreiben sie nicht an und sagen so
liebst du alle an wie sagst du nicht
dass du gehst sie heißt und wie sie max
für das team reist da ist doch
eigentlich probier oder den börsen
also bleibt ganz froh dass das jetzt
erst mit dem thema einberufen wo jetzt
bisschen älter bin bei dir was du damals
mit 18 durch denkt man dass man schnell
aber nicht so ganz
das hast du nicht so mache einfach mal
kann es ein bisschen geld mitverdienen
so aber jetzt denke ich nur ich hätte
das jetzt nicht wieder machen aber
nochmal du hast die folge nicht geschaut
dass ich kein einziges mal gesehen
oder doch eher einmal nachhaltig also
auf youtube der nähe als den fernseher
und dann machst du ne frau ich nicht
noch mal okay alles klar
ok dann gehe ich trotzdem zuschauer
fragen höre sich schon mal auf insgesamt
vier vorangestellt übrigens internet
gezockt abonniert was marihuana als 131
bank wie schwer ist es dir gefallen die
rolle ernst zu spielen
also war das 16 ja auch bei den folgen
dass leute sich aber so eine
nachbetrachtung möglichen geräte also
manchmal muss ich sagen wir das wirklich
schwerer über manchmal das lachen
verpasst doch kein normaler mensch
machen wie mit dieser mangel wenig
stammend schließen so war es doch kein
normaler mengen an gewinne mit kakao
aber ekelhaft und dann musste ich mich
wirklich so zusammen reist stoffel
mussten die szene so oft drehen wird so
ekelhaft sagt aber auch dass tatsächlich
gut gespielt also beim wechsel nämlich
auch schon ein paar folgen gesehen was
man sonst so sieht das war echt gut
also da habe ich gesagt das kann man
nicht so grottenschlecht wie sonst
ist das absicht dass es so schlecht
gespielt ist ich glaube ja also ich hab
immer davon aus dass es halt leute sind
die halt denken einfach mal damit lärm
den text auswendig der in dem dicht und
so stehen ja noch da und lesen das man
halt wirklich ab unter ich wenn ich mir
selber angucke und dann wirklich leute
da sehen sie dass so viel ablesen
marini freiheit muss das kamerateam auch
ab und zu oder wird der dreh sehr ernst
genommen
ja super mario auf annahme ist jetzt
wirklich so bestimmt nicht hin sind da
müssen sie sich auch manchmal nichts
zusammengepasst am meisten gelacht bei
dem dreh weißt du das noch
das ist auch gar nicht weil youtube
dabei das ist nur weil der original
folge dann dabei wir haben eine szene
gedreht da wurden wir nur als kasse
beobachtet ich und dieser tobias wir
wurden nur beobachtet von der kamera
weil meine mutter irgendwo weiter hinten
stand und wir mussten uns irgendwie
kernstadt kaugummis oder so in den mund
wer vom pc wusste ich warum keine angst
da habe ich mich so reden und dann
musste ich die ganze zeit so lachen und
ich kann einfach nicht ernst bleiben und
dann wollten die dass wir uns küssen
also diesen film kuss machen weil er
dachte dass das geht einfach nicht ich
konnte aber nicht ernst bleiben schaust
du so auch hilfe folgen also jetzt wenn
er eigentlich genau sehr selten also es
läuft so ab und zu mal aber ich mache
mich hauptsächlich eigentlich nur lustig
wird sich versagen aber kann es auch so
kommt man kann sie auch einfach nicht so
als ist es ernst und mehr sagt immerhin
verblödung
es ist auch so aber ich persönlich weiß
er selber dass es halt einfach nur
schwarze ist und deswegen ich und
einfach lustig mal zu gucken
einige sehen da war ein als vampir
verkleideter dachte papier also eine
frage die heute auch permanent gestellt
haben ist du hast schon wissen so ziert
dieses thema
würdest du nachher sagen dass es dir
peinlich ist der wirt gemacht sagen oh
das ist ja so ja aber gemacht wurde ich
hab's gemacht kann es nicht mehr ändern
aber ich finde jetzt der erste teil ist
jetzt gar nicht so schlimm
ja noch aber wie gesagt das endet das
ist ein wirklich so nee da doch gar
nicht also ein bisschen 'schon ja dass
hier warum mitgemacht hast war weil weil
jungen als nicht so viel geld ist halt
gut dafür immer besser als geldern für
acht euro die stunde oder so was
man hat halt relativ schnell eine höhere
menge an geld für dich jetzt mal sagen
aber wie gesagt es ist halt kein
millionenbetrag zehntausender betrag so
aber wie gesagt man halt ein bisschen
jünger ist dann ist das für ein halt
schon gutes geld wenn man halt in dem
sinne elf in der unter studiert hat oder
als meinen mitteln der ausbildung steckt
das unternehmen jedenfalls gehe ich aus
man für irgendwas gut zurecht
da ist nämlich auch ganz wichtig leute
vanessa hatte auch mit kanada ist der
erste link in der beschreibung unbedingt
abchecken da ist doch wir machen so ein
bisschen drüber geredet hast damit du
dich war er wie lange dauern die
dreharbeiten also wieder gedreht fünfte
folge fünf tage fünf tage krank ok dann
zum abschluss von rick sexy ist alles
gescriptet alles wie weit geht so das
scripting als seien wir dann so du musst
die augen aufreißen an der stelle oder
schülern also steht auch genau wo man um
an daten stehen sofern ebenso fahren
weil das hat glaube ich schon von
unserem interview vielen dank dass du
dich bereit erklärt kannst du bisschen
mit mir darüber zu reden welche youtube
kanal wird jetzt abonniert
drei leute